all right
are we all good
perfect
hello everyone and welcome to this talk
on c-sharp 8 9 and 10 and 11 and 12 and
whatever is coming next in this amazing
programming language
which is slowly turning into f sharp
it is amazing though that the
programming language has evolved quite a
lot over the past 10 years there's been
so many changes to the language it can
be a little bit hard to keep track on
what's happening with c sharp and why
you would want to use some of the new
language features
but just because there's a new language
feature doesn't mean that you have to
use it it's there to use for the purpose
that where you might need it in your
applications
so let's get through a few of those
really amazing language features that
will hopefully help you build really
great applications before that my name
is phillip eckberg
if you have any questions feel free to
ping me on twitter afterwards i have a
free book on c-sharp that you can
download as well just ping me afterwards
if there's anything that you want to
discuss in terms of c-sharp
so with that out of the way let's talk
about all the really great features of
c-sharp this here is a tag cloud of all
the language features added up until
let's say c sharp eight
and there's really
quite some of the features that were
added over the years that change the way
that we build software that changes the
fundamental way of how we look at
expressing ourselves
in terms of working with generics that
change the way how we work with
collections
maybe before that was added to the
language
many developers thought that maybe we
don't need that we can go by by using
the old arraylist that we used in the
past and the same goes for async and
await that was added to the language
quite late but it changed the way that
we consume asynchronous apis it changed
the way that we express ourselves and
it's an addition to the language that
let us build more powerful applications
and i guess that's true for all the new
language features as well they seem to
add new features that help us express
ourselves in ways that requires less
code but if it's used improperly that
may tend to make the applications
unreadable
so with as with any language feature use
it with caution
what's great about the development of
c-sharp as a programming language is
that it's open source you can
participate in the discussions around
which features do you want what's the
purpose of one of these new language
features
what's the the ideas behind it and how
are they going to implement that
maybe you want to participate in talking
about how you would like to see new
features in the language as well
i
tend to spend some time here just
looking at what's coming in the next
versions of the language just to keep
track on really what's happening
but one of the things that i learned
from the early on when they did this
when they open source c sharp is that
even if they talk about new language
features being added to the language
unless it's actually shipped there's no
guarantee that it will make it into the
next version
so you might read a lot about features
that might be coming in c sharp 11 and
12 but until they actually ship that
version of the compiler together with a
runtime
don't just expect that that's going to
make it into the language
we'll talk about one of those features
in just a moment
that's been caught up cut out of the
language
so
what's happened over the years i have
some highlights from c sharp 7 that's
fundamental to what's happening in the
new versions of c sharp and one of the
really big changes they made in c sharp
7 is changing the way that we look at
tuples or tuples depending on where
you're from we really talk about the
same same thing
so in the early days we had this type in
c sharp that allowed us to work with
this container of multiple different
values
but as of c 7 this became a first class
citizen so now we can just define this
this tuple in line like this here and
it's a first class citizen in the
language
it's a really small change but it's one
of the fundamental things that helped us
then get other really great features
into the language in terms of pattern
matching and deconstruction and working
with with containers of data
so with this introduced in the language
it also meant that we can now look at
how types can be deconstructed and turn
into something that looks like tuples
which is where this new concept of
adding a method to any given type in
your applications called the construct
as long as you have a method called
deconstruct and you have a few out
parameters that means that you can take
this object and pull it apart in
different ways
so if i have this on a person class for
instance that would mean that i can take
an instance of my person and deconstruct
that into two new local variables
looks very much like a tuple but it
isn't this here is in fact declaring two
local variables and i can then use them
in my context
and again this is something which is in
its own maybe not very useful but when
it comes to combining this with the
concept of pattern matching and writing
more expressive code this is becoming
really interesting to work with
another example to
with where this is used together with
tuples and and deconstructions is if we
have this concept of the right hand side
is declaring a tuple and i'm then
deconstructing that into two nuclear new
local variables
i can then use this in my context as the
properly named types
and again that might not seem very
useful but when it comes to
deconstructing an actual type that
declares exactly what this contains we
could then deconstruct deconstruct that
object and this is all done by just
introducing this method on your type you
can have multiple different deconstruct
methods on your type and that would
allow you to pull that object apart
and the reason you want to do this is
because then you can look at
the exact thing that you deconstruct an
object to
when it comes to pattern matching which
was in its turn introducing c sharp
seven as well
pattern matching we'll get into that as
well but it's a way for us to look at an
object and how that is expressed and
what it contains and what the attributes
are of that object
and while that was introduced in c sharp
7 it was kind of a first first attempt
at just making that into the language
and making people aware of how to use
patterns and pattern matching
so with two of these highlights out of
the way in c sharp seven there's many
more features that was introduced in
this language version but these are the
ones that we need to keep in mind to
fully understand some of the the rest of
the work that has gone into the compiler
so if we talk about c sharp 8 and kind
of what's beyond that which is the
purpose of this talk there's been a lot
of changes in the language they've
introduced a lot of language features
and if we just look at the list of
features that they've added we can start
off by talking about the read-only
members and there's default interface
implementations i'll show an example of
this soon but it's this is kind of a
divider of either you love it or you
hate it
which isn't really true for many
language features
i personally don't like it but we'll
talk about that soon they did some
pattern matching enhancements i'm not
going to talk about all of these here
but the highlighted ones are the ones
that i want to talk about we have
pattern matching enhancements really
it's the i would say this is the pattern
matching 1.0 because it made it really
purposeful in the language
we've got something called nullable
reference types and asynchronous streams
those three features that's what we're
going to be focusing on for a little
while here before we go on to the next
version of c sharp
so as you see here like as of
c sharp 8 which is the eighth eighth is
iteration of the language there's still
a lot of features being added to the
language some of them are improvements
to what was already added before
but some of them are really new concepts
as well and what i like about the
additions to c-sharp is that the
language team looks at earlier or other
versions of other programming languages
and take inspiration from f-sharp kotlin
swift and they even talk to the other
language designers on those teams to get
inspiration of what do we want to add to
the language
and when it makes the cut to c-sharp
they also need to make sure that it
feels like a c-sharp language version or
c-sharp feature
so it doesn't feel like it's a kotlin
version of a language feature just add
it into the language it needs to feel
like it's a feature built for c-sharp
developers
so if i want to use all of these new
things in c sharp
how do i go about that
a change that i've also made is that
some of the newer versions of the
language require you to jump on a new
runtime
and that means if you want to use c
sharp 8 9 and 10 you have to use the
corresponding.net runtime
now given that we have net framework
before and now.netcore and
then.net.net again it can be a little
bit confusing which one you want to use
if you want to use c sharp eight you
have to do visual studio 2019 or later
and dot net course 3.0 and 4.95 it's c
sharp 9 and so forth
so every version or every
long term support version of the runtime
will have a corresponding c-sharp
language version with features added
and the reason the they're doing this is
because they can now also make changes
to how things work in the runtime they
can add language features that depend on
runtime changes as well
and i guess that's not really a problem
anymore back in the in the day when you
had to update your dotnet framework on a
physical server that was a little bit
more of a risk doing that
but nowadays when you just deploy a new
docker container with a new version of
net and if that doesn't work you just
fall back
there's really not a risk anymore just
upgrading your net runtime
at least not as much as in the past
so given that we have to work with dot
net core or dot net five or six and
onwards it also means that they had to
update the
the templates for wpf and winforms so we
can create wpf apps and winforms
applications or xamarin or maui versions
that are able to target dot net core and
later so that means that pretty much
every version of of c sharp cannot be
used in the different types of projects
now i did mention that there's one
language feature that they introduced
that i don't particularly like so if we
create one of these new projects and i
decide to use this new thing called
default interface implementations
that means that i can now add
implementation details to my to my
interface so look here this is an
interface
and then i have an implementation of
that while i'm using an
expression-bodied member here i'm still
i still have implementation details
about what happens when i call this
method
that means that whoever implements this
interface
don't have to implement this method
themselves
which can be a little bit weird right
because it means that
the interface now has
logic on it which we didn't we weren't
able to do that in the past
the only difference between this and
multiple inheritance is that we don't
have the actual instance to work with
this is great for library developers
that want to introduce breaking changes
or update their libraries without
breaking everyone
there's very few things that are more
annoying than updating a new get package
and you're required to implement like 10
different interfaces
or additional methods on an interface
so this is a great option for that but
it also means that if there's already an
implementation the compiler won't tell
you that you have to implement that
method so you wouldn't know that there's
a new method available on the interface
that you just updated
which can be a little bit problematic
now if we're targeting multiple
different types of applications and
multiple different types of runtimes
this might not be available so if we're
using a shared library like i'm doing
here
it's going to tell me that
the target runtime that you're now
compiling for doesn't support default
implement default interface
implementations
so while you can still write the actual
code here and the compiler tells you
that if you're targeting let's say.net
framework with the same.net standard
library it will tell you that you can't
compile for that particular target but
you can still use that language feature
in a shared library and compile for the
particular platform that it works on
so as i said earlier this here is kind
of a divider like either you love this
or you really hate it
but for library developers it's a great
language feature
all right so
probably one of my favorite language
features added for a very long time is
something called nullable reference
types
now i take it that most of you have had
a null reference exception in the past
anyone that hasn't have a null reference
exception you are lying
because that never happens right you're
gonna have get a no reference exception
unless it's maybe your first day as a
developer like then i totally accept
that you haven't had this but maybe
tomorrow
so
what do we do if we cannot go back in
time and fix the mistake of adding nulls
in the language like adding a null or
making it easy to add null in c sharp is
really a design flaw now i'm not i'm not
a language designer but i can still
appreciate that
it is a fault to the language making it
easy to add that to the languages or in
your applications is really not good
so what do we do we add
support in the language to let us know
when there is a potential problem
and this is where nullable reference
types come into play
now the naming here is
in my opinion not very good
because it
nullable reference types has always been
nullable
so what does this actually mean
they gave it this name because we had
nullable value types which means that
you can add a little question mark to
your value types and all of a sudden you
they're now reference types and you can
set them to null but since reference
types has always been able to be null
this should really be called
non-nullable reference types
because that's what's going to happen
so let's go and have a look at what that
looks like in just a moment
we're all familiar with this problem
here right
if you haven't seen this it's just a
matter of time
but really why did we get a null
reference exception in some of these
applications obviously we we can't go in
and check all of these problems but
what's the problem with nullability
except or
despite of the fact that it
it costs a lot of money to fix
the problem is that
we we're going to make our code harder
to read we're going to have null checks
everywhere
and and writing code just for the
purpose of there might be a problem that
i haven't designed my application for
i don't particularly like that
it would be much better if i had to
explicitly determine when could
something be null when could this
potentially be a problem when is it my
intent that this could be null
but when something can be null what does
that actually mean
it's pretty ambiguous right because if i
return knowledge from a method call
did something happen was there a problem
i expected maybe a result coming back
from a database and if that returns null
does it mean the the record didn't exist
does it mean that there was a problem in
my my particular method
who knows it's an ambiguous thing right
so we want to be very explicit about
what null actually means
and it also encourages mutability
and that means we can have issues with
when it comes to multi-threaded
applications or asynchronous programming
so really all of this is telling us that
we want to avoid nulls in the indie
language and we're in our applications
we want to go ahead and use something
else
but we also want to get the help of
c-sharp as a programming language to
tell us when there might be a problem
because we want to avoid this here so
obviously this here checks if my object
is null it then checks a property and
then another property on that we can
simplify this by using the null
conditional operator or we can use
pattern matching we can write this in
like as many people there are in this
room we can probably express this in a
different manner
the solution to this
is to enable a nullable context
we can do this by using a compiler
directive
or we can do this on the project level
if i do this it's going to change the
way the compiler looks at all my
reference types
what happens is that all reference types
are now assumed to have a value if they
don't the compiler is going to give us a
warning
and there's very much help in the
language that are going to tell us if
there is something that could
potentially cause a problem
it sounds awesome it sounds like it's
going to fix all of our problems
but of course i'm going to show you how
we break this later
so what it does is that
in this case here i have my string here
very simple example string name is equal
to null and right off the back you can
see here that it's this
little squiggly here and that is now
indicating that we have a warning it's
warning me that you should probably not
set this to null
because the compiler is now looking at
the string here as something that should
never be set to null
it's even telling us here that name here
could potentially be null so calling dot
split here
will most likely cause a problem
so
how did this fix anything
well it didn't but we at least we found
a place where it could potentially be an
issue
so how about we jump into visual studio
and just look at an application and i'm
going to enable notable reference types
font size good in the back
perfect
so
if we go into the project file
you'll see here
that i can enable something
called nullable
and if i do that it's going to change
the way the compiler looks at the
application
if we just
comment that out again and just look at
the application
if we look at these two classes there's
nothing in here that looks odd there's
nothing in here that looks out of the
way or out of the ordinary
but as soon as i enable this
this
this nullable context
and just save this here
and go back hopefully
it's going to give us some squiggles
here to tell us that well
details here should probably contain a
value
so to get rid of this here we need to
ensure that
both my property details and the first
name and the last name that they're all
set to a value to get rid of this
warning we could simply say that i
really allow this to be null
and all of a sudden the warning just
disappeared
now i'm not suggesting that we should
have question marks all over the place
just to get rid of all the warnings
instead there's an alternative approach
so what we can do let's do this for
let's do it for the person or the
details down here at the bottom i'm
going to introduce a constructor
and if i do that
and if i can scroll down here we go
the warnings disappeared from first name
and last name and that's really great
but they're now giving a warning on the
constructor instead and telling me that
you have two properties that are marked
as not being allowed to be null and you
should probably set them to a value
i could add them to
to my constructor
and let's say last name
and i could set first name and last name
to
the corresponding first name come on
writing and talking at the same time
always very easy here we go
and last lasting
so of course now i don't have a problem
here anymore
but the issue with this is that i've now
changed the contracts so every anyone in
the application that is now using this
class they're now required to
instantiate this with these two
with these two these two constructor
parameters
and that's not very good because now i
probably have a lot more issues in the
application
and honestly
null wouldn't be a problem in this case
here
there are
many ways that we can approach this as
as i said earlier as many developers
that there are in here we can approach
this in different ways but changing the
contract we could probably agree that
sure this is a great approach if it's
the first version of the the code base
it's a new application that we are
coding but if this is a five-year-old
application that we are updating it's
probably not a good idea to just go in
and change all your your classes
is it gonna have a lot of compiler
errors
and honestly in here the problem with
nullability or being null was probably
not first name last time in details so
in this case i'm going to allow these to
be null
now of course i have three question
marks here but at least
we got rid of the warnings so what did
this change change
now anyone that's using these different
properties will now be warned that you
should probably
go ahead and do a null check
let me zoom out here just a little bit
here we go
so now since i'm accessing details here
the compiler doesn't know that this
could potentially be set to an instance
so this here would be causing a null
reference exception if we have just a
new instance of this this class
or if we have if we didn't have an
instance of the class it would this
would cause a problem
again there are multiple ways to solve
this we could say that well if if
details is null don't go ahead and get
the first name and we've
we've fixed that problem so now we're
not going to get a null reference
exception
but of course is that if that was an
input parameter to another method this
would this expression would yield null
and we could have more problems you see
where we're getting at we have to really
think about the architecture and how we
approach this
but at least the compiler told us that
if you're not sure that this is
null checked you're going to have a
problem
we could also do we could call argument
null exception throw if null
and pass in person dot details
and all of a sudden
the the warning disappeared
this is because there's something called
the
the attributes for null state static
analysis which is quite a mouthful to
say
so what it does is that it knows that
i've performed a null check it knows
that if this throws an exception
it's properly done in null check
so that's why the warning disappeared
here but now i've explicitly said that
this is going to throw an exception
because i don't expect this to ever be
no
if that happens it's going to tell
whoever's consuming this that we had a
problem and they can go ahead and handle
that
so we fixed this method here
but i know that there's still another
warning
this is not really a good idea right
returning null here is quite ambiguous
so what i can do to get rid of this
warning like i can't add a question mark
here because i guess that doesn't make
any sense
but what i can do
i can promise the compiler that this
isn't null
and there's no warning
but again i guess this is not the best
approach
so what i want to do is that i want to i
really want to fix this problem using
the the exclamation mark to solve this
is just for cases where you really know
better than the compiler
which is never
so try not to use the exclamation mark
instead we are going to fix this by
creating a new instance of a person can
do our person is equal to new person
and i'll i'll show you a pretty cool
language feature
called target type new expression so if
i don't want to
explicitly say that this is a new
details i could instead say that this is
just a new
and it would just automatically figure
out
which type it is
which in this case
well just writing out details wouldn't
make like wouldn't use very many
characters but if this was a very
complex generic type
being able to just use a shorthand would
be really nice i could say first first
name is philip
i can't even spell my own name
i'm not going to bother with last name
and then
i can do yield return person
this is a pretty cool hack so whenever
you have an i innumerable of person or
innumerable of t
you don't have to explicitly
declare a new list or you don't have to
use a temporary array or anything like
that you can use a yield keyword to
create an iterator
which is a pretty cool shorthand way of
approaching this here so now we've fixed
all the null reference exception in the
application
right and we learned that if we if we
really have a no we'll use the
exclamation mark to
just force this to um
to work now there's one more setting
that we can change which is treat
warnings as errors
if i uncomment this here
and let's just
do verb or do person is equal to p is
equal to no
again i can't even spell
look here what's going to happen now
it's going to give me a compiler warning
because we're not allowed
to set this to null anymore
now all the warnings in the application
are going to be treated as non-nullable
all the reference types are going to be
treated as non-nullable and as long as
there is a warning
it's going to give us
an error instead
so
this is a good idea if you know that you
don't have many warnings in the
application
i mostly don't look at the warnings tab
because there's too many so treating
them as errors is probably not the best
approach for me personally
but i know that many projects or many
larger organizations like to keep the
warnings at a minimum make sure that
everything is done explicitly because a
warning is there for a reason
so what you want to do here is that you
just want to go ahead and fix the
problems
and again i guess if we have an
exclamation mark here
and just promise that this isn't null
um
that is going to just get rid of that
compiler warning
all right so
this is a very good option you can do
this in the project settings as well
the same goes for turning on the
nullable context you can do that inside
each project it's a per project setting
and actually what i didn't show you
i forgot you can enable and disable this
with a compiler directive so you can say
nullable disable if you really don't
want to go ahead and fix that particular
method at this time it might be that
this method is too complex to sort out
or you look at it the other way around
if you just disable the nullable
nullable reference types for the entire
project you can enable this
for one method at a time
which will help you slowly refactor
parts of the application
i guess that this is the the second best
thing that we can get if we can't go
back in time because we can't go back
and just remove nulls from the language
completely
right so this is pretty much my favorite
feature from c sharp 8.
actually i love this feature as well
asynchro streams is also one of those
things that is going to make our lives a
little bit easier
i i really like asynchronous programming
and if you've seen any of my courses on
pluralsight you know that i i've done
quite a bit of courses on asynchronous
programming
and it's because it's one of those
things that let us express ourselves in
a way that was really hard before async
and await and task and all of that was
introduced in the language
so being able to stream data
synchronously retrieve items in a way
that
really is fluent to read and easy to
understand i think that's a really great
addition to the language
it all comes down to this pattern here
so
again we have this
we have this method here
where you have an async keyword if you
have if you've ever used asynchronous
programming in c sharp before you know
that the async keyword is is most of the
time it's paired with a task like object
now in this case here i have something
called i
innumerable of a string
what this means here is that it's going
to give me strings
streaming strings into my application
and it's going to give me each item
asynchronously
right so each item is going to be
retrieved maybe from a file on disk
maybe it's going to give me this from a
database or an api
we don't know
so this here indicates that the data
will be streamed
right
and how do we stream something back well
we introduce what i just showed you the
yield keyword
so the yield keyword will tell the
iterator that there's now an item to be
processed
and we only use the yield keyword once
we've in fact
retrieved some data so what i'm going to
do here is that i'm going to use
readline async just to read one line at
a time from a file on my disk and then
i'm going to await that to just do this
asynchronously and then i i have this
this fake task.delay to just simulate
that this is done from a web call or
something like that
if i ran this code on an old machine
like my when i was a kid which is those
spinning hard drives this would have i
wouldn't have needed that test ideally
because everything took so much time
but nowadays with all the fast ssds and
fast computers
i really have to fake the deal just to
show exactly how this works
so this here is producing a stream of
data but what's important to know as
well as with any innumerables it doesn't
really start iterating through the data
unless you consume it
and you consume this together with the
for reach keyword right
so to do this we have a wait for each
and we retrieve each element from that
method
let me show you how this works
so i've created
i'm using visual studio code now just to
spice it up a little bit
i have this this this to produce a
stream i've introduced an async
innumerable offstring called get lyrics
and what it's it's going to do here is
that it's also using one of the new
language features called a using
declaration notice how it doesn't open
and close the using declaration that's
because it's going to make sure that
it's disposed of when this method
completes
and this method is going to stream data
back to whoever consumes this stream of
data so this using block won't or this
using statement won't dispose until all
of that is done
right and then
we have this while away stream dot
reline async is a string line
so this here i'm combining the await
keyword with a pattern matching
to check that whatever this returns
it needs to be an instance of a string
and i'm going to capture that into a
local variable that's only available in
this for in this in this while loop
and then i'm going to have a task delay
and then yield return now this here is
going to to stream this data back to
whoever consumed that consumes this
stream of data
so to do that
i'm going to say await for each
var line and get lyrics
copy that
and oh this here is the new top level
statements introduced in csharp9 it
means that you don't have to use the
public static void main
stuff anymore it makes it much more
streamlined to produce your applications
or produce your program files which is
nice for something called minimal apis
if we have some time over i can show you
that as well
so now this here is a little bit
different
the await keyword is in in front of the
for each now normally
if you use the async and away keywords
and test the test parallel library you
would have had the await keyword in
front of the method call that would mean
that it would wait for that entire chunk
of data to be completed
but what this means now if we move it to
the front means that
for each element that we are going to
get that is going to be retrieved
asynchronously so i can do
console.writeline
and i'll print the line
like this here
and now it's going to stream this to my
console
let's do this dot net run
hopefully each item is now streamed into
the console while this is compiled and
executed
or maybe it just doesn't work look at
that
it works world's best song
perfect now
so for sure this is a little bit
different now there's one thing i want
to tell you here which is kind of true
for all i enumerables
you never really know how much data is
going to be inside of it
so whenever you do for instance two
array
how would it know when to stop how would
it know
when to finish
producing this array of data we don't
know if this here is a this is a
database call or if this is a file
that's just filled with text as we read
it right so
never do two array or two lists on your
innumerables unless you know that it's
it's filled with data
that's a little bit tip
all right
so now we're going to be talking about
syrup 9.
we've actually looked at a few features
from both c sharp 9 10 um in this demo
as well but i'd like to talk about
something called record types which is
one of the features that was the
the idea behind bringing c sharp and vb
as open source and rebuilding the
compilers one of the first projects they
wanted to do with this or the first
language features they wanted to
introduce was at the time called primary
constructors which really is what record
types are all about
it took quite a long time to get this
language feature done and get it to a
state where it makes sense for everyone
or some trade-offs that they had to make
now this here provides a concise syntax
of defining your your types or your
reference types it can also sfc sharp 10
be used with structs
what it also does is that it comes with
a lot of built-in functionality out of
the box
it provides value-based equality it
allows you to print the object in all
its properties as a string in a very
nice nice format
what also came with c sharp nine unless
when you can't do
records records are immutable as well
and i'll show an example of that
but what they also introduce is
something called init only setters
so let me just bring this over here
let's see here there we go
i didn't show you this but what we have
is on if we look at the details
there's this this little thing here
called init
that means that once you've set this to
a value using the object initializer you
cannot change this anymore
so it's like you set it once and then
it's set forever until you create a new
instance and copy the value
so that was introduced in c sharp nine
as well and called init only setters
and we just looked at what's called top
level statements
that's the idea behind just allowing you
to just write code in your program.cs
why would you have to write all the
boilerplate stuff inside your program
that doesn't really make sense and it's
it's not only meant for new developers
to easily get into c-sharp but as i
mentioned it's also one of those things
that makes it easy for us to write very
minimal applications that might be
deployed as a small docker container
it's very self-contained in a small very
small file
we also got really pattern matching
enhancement there's a lot of changes to
pattern matching and pattern matching is
one of those things that's being changed
i i would say that with every version of
c sharp coming forward there's going to
be changes to pattern matching we're
going to spend some time showing you all
the patterns that have been added
we looked at the target type new
expression as well which is a nice
addition to c sharp
does it it
removes the idea of just having to
explicitly define the type when you
create an instance
and there's a lot more added to the
language again like this here is quite a
lot of features
to add
to one iteration of the language
and i just want to emphasize that you
don't have to use all of this you don't
have to understand all the language
features but if you find yourself in a
situation where you feel like is there a
smarter way to solve my particular
problem or express myself in a different
way there might be a new language
feature that allows you to do that and
also give you some some
nice code generated out of the box
that's
probably more more fault safe than what
you could potentially write yourself
so i've mentioned pattern matching quite
a lot and we haven't discussed exactly
what this entails or what that means to
the language
pattern matching as a concept is really
simple it's the idea of being able to
determine what certain things are
is it a yellow fruit is it a banana is
it a puzzle piece that looks in this
particular way is it
an ikea poster that's
extremely incorrect it actually looks
like the furniture that i tend to build
myself but
so we can use pattern matching to
determine those different things it's
not all only for determining the color
but it's it's for so much more we can
use it to drill down into an object and
determine exactly what it contains what
it inherits from and so forth
but matching on a given type and the
attributes i have the attributes in
quotes here because it's not the
attributes that you put on your your
methods or on your classes it's the
attributes in terms of what is this
right so in c sharp one through six the
way that you would build this is that
would you would get the type and compare
that to whatever you're looking for then
you would check the property of that
given type and if you have to use this
as the concrete type you would have to
cast this yourself
there's nothing wrong with this piece of
code here it's just a little bit more
code than we have than what we have to
write
so as of c sharp 7 they introduced a way
for us to use a switch the switch
statement to determine
sort of this the same thing but in a
little bit more of a concise manner well
i wouldn't say concise because it's a
lot more code but you get the idea right
we can express ourselves in a similar
way but what we don't have here there's
no casting involved here
we don't have to cast this particular
type into the concrete type before we
use this inside the
inside of the case here
so it's a little bit different
so personally sfc sharp 7 i wouldn't
really use this because it didn't make
my code much more readable but
then
something called switch expressions was
introduced this is a new way of looking
at
at an object
so here we say i want to get a result
based off what this this object is and
we can create patterns to determine that
so we have the the input here could be
anything and i want to create a switch
block
that contains a lot of expressions
the expressions will then or the
patterns
will then determine what this is
to make it simple we could say that
if the fruit here is an apple i'm going
to return the string this is an apple
and for everything else this here is a
discard
the discard will in fact match on nulls
as well it will match on anything that
is not of that particular type
they don't even have to share the same
base type when it comes to pattern
matching if you have an object passed
into the method that's using the type
object it could match on anything you
could imagine strings ends and whatnot
so this here looks a little bit more
tidy
right and this here is what's returned
so we're going to be spending some time
looking at different ways of writing
patterns because it's much more powerful
than just returning strings like this
here
so in c sharp there are
multiple different patterns and as i
mentioned they are adding much more to
this as well what we just saw here was a
type pattern it matches the particular
type that we're looking for
we have something called a positional
pattern which uses the deconstruct
method imagine that i deconstruct an
object and i know that the first
parameter is the first name the second
one is the last name i could say find
all the people in this list of of people
that have the last name of ekberg for
instance which is my last name
it would then be able to match that
because it could be deconstructed that's
the positional pattern
we can look at different properties to
determine what they contain
we can match on tuples or tuples
we can use a relational pattern
imagine that i could say give me all the
people inside this array here that are
between the age 20 and 40.
right that's where the conjunctive and
and disjunctive or patterns come into
play as well because then i could say
give me everyone from
from the age of 20 to 40 or the people
that are in this other age range
and i can use something called
parenthesis pattern and i can negate
patterns using a knot pattern and i can
use recursive patterns recursive
patterns simply put means that we're
combining multiple patterns together
for instance give me a person that is
also this age
let's have a look at a few of these
different patterns
so
pattern matching alone there's a lot of
patterns available in c sharp
but we're going to look at a few of them
i'm going to just add a new project
just to show you the new project
template again
i'll add a new console application
let's use dot net six doesn't matter but
we can do dotnet six
and this here is now the new project
template available in net six c sharp
c-sharp nine
what this allows us to do is is write
some very nice code without having to
introduce um all of that boilerplate
code that we had before i'm going to
bring in a file here called test results
this is not kovi test results this here
is like for a university or something
like that so
if you're like me you kind of had to
take the test multiple time to pass
especially if it's math that's not
really my thing so therefore i have a
property called number of tests
if it was a valid or if it was a past
test say that which date that was tested
on this is a very just simple simple
object just to represent some data and
give you an idea of what we can do with
pattern matching
then i have this deconstruct method
which deconstructs this object it takes
a test result and it allows you to give
you how many days ago did you take this
test and was this a valid or a passed
test
and as you see here when you build this
deconstruct method it doesn't have to
correspond exactly with the properties
or fields that you have on your class we
can build this uh we can we can do
computation in here to determine uh for
in this case how many days since we took
the test so
if we have an instance let's say that we
have a test result
we are now going to assume that we got
this out of a method call
test result
it's using the base base test result
because i also have a negative and a
positive test result should be passed or
failed
um
could also be password failsory so if i
just instantiate this with a new
positive
test
of course in this case here i know that
it's positive but
we could again imagine that this came
out of a method called
i can use pattern matching in multiple
different ways i could say that if the
test result
if the test results
is positive
i could then enter this if block here so
i don't have to use this with the switch
or the switch expression i can use this
with that as well here i could say that
if this test result is not positive
right so i can negate that type pattern
using the not in front of all the
patterns that you have on the right hand
side means that it will negate that
entire thing it doesn't just negate the
first part of the pattern it negates
everything you have to the right hand
side
that's very important to keep in mind
now obviously it would be better to just
swap that around
i don't really want to see you doing
like if it's not false
because that doesn't make any sense
so again you can abuse the language
features but you shouldn't
but what i can do here is that i can say
if it's positive
and then to do ticket property
i can say if the number of tests
actually listed not if the number of
tests are more than than
say more than two
then i want to enter this this if block
here
but as we don't know if this here is in
fact like i'd have to in this case i'd
have to cast the
let's do this just to show you exactly
where result
is equal to test result
i'd have to do this right to be able to
access the properties that are only
available on the particular on that
particular
type as the concrete type but what i can
do with pattern matching is that i can
use something called a var pattern
or declaration pattern sorry to say that
i want to capture this
once you've validated all the patterns i
can then capture this as a local
variable called positive and i can now
access all the properties that are
available on this actual type
and if i zoom in here
you'll see that it's in fact the type
positive so it cast that for me
automatically this won't work for every
different case when it cannot determine
like if you're using an or pattern to
say if this is positive or negative it
wouldn't know exactly what that would be
at compile time
then you would have to cast it yourself
again i can then combine these different
patterns by using and or ors
it's a mouthful to say that so i could
say if it's positive
maybe this is hard to read but
let's see here and
let's do it on one line sorry
and it's less than five less than or
equal to five
i can say that when this is positive and
it's between two and five
so i could use this with ifs i could use
it with the with the switch expression
as well i'll show you a few more
patterns as well so i mentioned that the
test result here introduces something
called this deconstruct and i want to
use that now to write a pattern that
matches this particular test result to
show you an example of of
how to write unreadable code what you
should avoid so let's say that we want
to want to figure out the outcome of
this of this test result so i could say
based on the test result we're going to
create a switch expression
and when i cannot determine what this is
i'm going to say that this is
incon
not available
i can even spell inconclusive so i'm not
going to attempt that now this works
like a normal switch block so if i try
to add something after the disc card
it's going to tell me that it's already
been pas already been matched on so you
have to use the
the more
granular ones at the top so since
discard is a catch all you'd have to to
move this one one line above
i can catch all the positive ones or i
can also say that when this here can be
deconstructed into something that where
i don't care about the first parameter
but the second one needs to be let's say
false
whatever this is
so this here
how would we know what that is like i
have no idea if surely enough when i
write the code it makes sense because i
look at the deconstruct method i write
my patterns but then tomorrow when i go
back to this code i'm
not going to have any idea at all what
this means
so you can use name parameters as well
you could say is valid because that's
what that
that is called the
as you'll see here it's called it's
valid in the deconstruct it uses the
deconstruct to pull that object apart
and then i say
for every test that is that is not valid
and again i could
negate that
to find all the ones that are positive
avoid that please so now
invalid
and again if i don't want to use the
deconstruct because it can get hard to
read if you have to use the deconstruct
or if you want to do that the same goes
for the tuple pattern they look the same
way
you should try to use name parameters
because otherwise it won't make any
sense at all
i could also combine this like i don't
have to use the deconstruct for all of
these different ones i could say that if
it's a positive test
where the number of tests the same that
we had earlier the number of tests are
more than or equal to two and less than
or equal to five
i can capture that as well and i can do
something with that value again it
doesn't have to return a string it could
also
construct a complex type as well
so as you'll see here you can combine
the different types of pattern matching
or the different types of patterns
available
you will probably find yourself using
this type pattern
together with the property pattern the
most or if you have a topple use the
tuple pattern which looks exactly like
this here
okay
let's go ahead
so for c sharp 10 oh sorry let's go
through this
so for c sharp 10 they made sure that we
can use record structs which is i'm
going to show you records that as the
last thing that we go through the
records tracks allows us to also use the
same syntax for producing value value
types that are records which comes with
the record type or all the record stuff
out of the box
in honest honestly one of like one of
the most important things in c sharp 10
is probably the global using directives
and the file scope names type namespace
declarations that means that you no
longer have to
you no longer have to
declare your namespace and wrap
everything like we do here
in a namespace so i can say that this
here is now going to be a part of the
namespace
ndc
and now this entire file is going to be
inside the namespace of ndc instead of
having to wrap this entire class inside
this this namespace it's just a matter
of indenting your code making it easier
i guess when reading this through
different types of tooling
and you can also say that if you want to
you can introduce a file or you can do
it anywhere in the application but you
can use something called global using
directives so you could say that i want
to be using
ndc for instance
but i can also say that this here is a
global using
to say that everything inside doesn't
make any sense here but
gives you an idea of this here
we could say that everywhere in the
application you no longer have to
introduce the using statement for ndc
it's just automatically going to be used
inside the entire application
can be confusing because what happens if
you bring in extension methods for
example you will have no idea where
they're coming from
so again just keep in mind that some of
these language features you should use
them with caution
all right so that's the global using
statements and file scope namespace
declarations they also make it easier to
do some property pattern for
for
further down like their extended
property pattern so if we were looking
at for example the test result and that
had a a property was also an in a
reference type that had a property that
you wanted to check on you can just do
you can just check the property using
the dot accessor i'll show you
let's get rid of this here
let's say that we had a
a property on here let's say that that
the is valid was a reference type
in the past you'd have to do something
like this here which wasn't very nice
you could say that it's valid that
object
had a certain value
right
would make it much more more flexible
so being cautious of time i want to show
you the final thing which is a really
great feature and that's the record
types
record types
let's say that i want to create a new
class called person which has a first
name and a last name
when i did this here now what happens is
that this here behind the scenes
introduces a new reference type it
creates or it generates a class a class
that has a deconstruct method on it
based on the different
the different properties that i defined
here it has two properties with backing
fields generated it has value-based
equality which means that if i create an
instance of this
new person whoops
new person
this will require me to enter my first
name
and my last name
like this here
this pus this is called a positional
record so when i have this this primary
constructor is what it's called it
requires me to pass those those
different fields i could add a body to
my record to introduce
more things more properties more
constructors more methods more whatever
you want the purpose of a record is to
hold data it's for replacing dtos and
making it easy to compare data but the
place where you cannot use it is with
entity framework because entity
framework relies on reference type
equality and as i mentioned uh record
types this is value based equality and
my last name is equity here we go so
what does that mean to be value-based
equality let's say that i have two
instances
i have philip and phillip two
they're both references or new instances
like this here
normally if we compare
to reference types
this would yield false but when it comes
to record types
this will compare the properties of
those generated classes so this here
would in fact yield true
of course if i change one of the one of
the
one of the properties or one of the
values this is going to be false which
kind of makes sense
what i can also do here if i don't want
to do this this entire new person if i
just want to copy this here or create a
new instance as i mentioned it's
immutable which means that i couldn't
say let's say that i want to change my
last name to
to something else or i want to change my
i want to create my wife's an instance
of my wife here
now instead of having to
to create that new instance i can use a
language feature called with expression
so instead of having to create this all
of that code i could say or sophie is
equal to philip
with a first name of
right
and this here will now create a copy of
all the values that are on my instance
and create this this separate instance
here as well
because i couldn't change the name if i
wanted to because all the properties are
read only
and i can prove that to you by going
over to
a place called sharplab.io
if that still works
here we go
so i've entered the same code here this
little thing here is in the way but i
promise it's it's the same thing
it's the record of person with a first
name and last name and the right hand
side here is all the code that's
generated when i enter this code here
let me scroll down just a little bit
here
we have a class here you see here class
person
it implements i equatable of person
the interface gives us a value-based
equality it then has two backing fields
that are read only means that we can
only set them once
it has properties that are exposing
these backing fields which means that we
can access them just us and and they're
marked as init which means that they can
be changed with that with expression
it then if we scroll down a little bit
here
we have
the operator overloads as well for
inequality for equality
and this will compare
all the backing fields with each other
i'm just going to scroll over to one of
them and show you first name backing
field
is equals to the other person's backing
so there's quite a lot of code coming
into this here by just writing record
person
so i would recommend that you use this
for everything that's a data
transmission or you have something
that's going over the wire you have some
really simple data containers in the
application but don't use it for entity
framework because that's not going to
work
i do expect that they're going to make
some changes with that
later on
all right um
let's see here they've also made some
other changes to c-sharp ten not as much
as in terms of c sharp eight nine and so
forth and the same really goes for c
sharp eleven
but we've looked at quite a few of the
features that are coming in c sharp ten
and one of them that they're adding
which is a preview feature in c sharp
ten that's also a concept they're trying
to do in in versions of c sharp coming
up it's adding preview features you can
enable the preview flag in both the
runtime and as well as the language
this here is static abstract members and
interfaces so i can change this static t
instance here to become abstract
right
and then that requires that whoever
implements the interface also
implements that that method but this
here is a dotnetpreview.6 preview
feature and it's going to be a part of c
sharp 11.
right so if we don't do that it's going
to tell us that we're if we're not
implementing it it's going to give us a
warning
another cool feature they're doing is
that we can use constant strings in
and using string interpolation
it's a nice addition we couldn't do this
previously
and
the natural type of the lambda which is
this called here so we have to
explicitly in c sharp nine we have to
explicitly determine what is this this
lambda going to be compiled to we have
to say well this is a func of string and
int
but the compiler could probably figure
this out by looking at the input
parameters and what it returns so that's
what they introduced here the natural
type of the lambda
and
this here is that you cannot figure that
out in c sharp 10.
and with that
we also got something called attributes
on lambdas
this here is a minimal api
i have this in a program.cs file and it
just spawns up a website for me list is
for this slash id path allows me to pass
in data which is gets from from some of
the headers
so i have about seven seconds left
so what's next
we've already talked about the fact that
whatever comes in c 11
might not even really
get into the language
but they're looking at more patterns how
do we match lists how do we use slices
of a list and look at that how can we
use something called a span pattern
there's something called name of
parameters we're going to be now finally
caching delegates so if you have a um
static method group it's no longer going
to have you have to create an instance
of that and do allocations even if it's
just for very high performance
applications where you would notice this
still a nice addition they're
introducing something called required
or required properties which means that
we could say that when you create an
instance of this using the object
initializer you are now required to set
this value
right
again we're working towards a a way of
immutability and where we force people
to correspond to what our types should
be
there's nothing called raw string
literals
static members and interfaces is going
to be added now as a real feature which
they've added as a preview feature in c
sharp 10.
this is called utf-8 string literals i
can take my string name here and just
map that into a span of bytes
so i don't have to manually cast that
into an utf-8 string this is really
handy if you have a lot of data that
comes over networking
generic attributes are also part of the
c-sharp 11 promised feature list
and then they've actually removed one of
the features that they've been
previewing for quite some time
they wanted to add
double bangs bang bang on input
parameters to methods and if that was
null it threw an exception
and a lot of people didn't like this
so they listened and they removed the
feature
so if you've been hoping for whatever
what this was called parameter null
checking if you really wanted that i'm
sorry to say that they've removed that
but again this language is being worked
on in the open so it means that you can
give input on things that
you want and don't want
if you like my stuff go ahead and check
out my courses on pluralsight i have a
lot of content on c sharp and i think
i'm out of time so with that being said
i hope you like this i hope you like c
sharp don't forget to vote on your way
out if you have any questions ping me on
twitter i'm phil beckberg thank you so
much